To find the first x intercept, I take my equation and I set y equal to 0. I know
any number times 0 is 0 so I have negative 2x equals 8. Dividing both sides by
negative 2, I get both sides equal to negative 4. So, our x intercept occurs at
x equals negative 4 and the point is negative 4, comma 0. For the Y intercept, I
set x equal to 0. Negative 2 times 0 is 0 and I'm left with 4Y is equal to 8. We
divide both sides by 4 to get y is equal to 2. So, our y intercept occurs at y
equals 2, but the point is 0, 2. For the second equation, we can find the x
intercept in the same way. We set y equal to 0. So this term drops out. And I
get 3x is equal to 6, then we divide both sides by 3, and x equals 2, so our x
intercept occurs at x equal 2 and we have the point 2 comma 0. This y intercept
is a little bit harder, we do the same process for y intercepts we set x equals
0, so x is 0, so am left with 9y equal to 6. We want to solve for y, so we need
to divide by 9. So I have y is equal to 6 9ths. If we remember back from
fractions, we know that a 3 goes into both the numerator and the denominator, so
I can simplify this fraction. 6 divided by 3 makes 2, and 9 divided by 3 makes
3, so I'm left with 2 3rds. 0 comma 2 3rds is our y-intercept here. For this
last equation, we can find the x intercept again by setting y equal to 0, then
solve for x and divide both sides by 4. 0 divided by 4 makes both sides 0. So,
our x intercept occurs at point 0,0. To find the Y intercept, you let x equal 0,
so I get y is equal to 0. Whoa. This is the same point and their both the origin
so something is going on with this line. We'll learn about this equation in the
upcoming lessons but if you're interested try graphing this and see if you can
figure out what's going on.